après la terreur l'exode d'une partie de
la population de bhopal en inde se
prépare à quitter la ville de crainte
d'une nouvelle catastrophe qui semble
pourtant très improbable on redoute à
popol la remise en marche de l'usiné de
pesticides qui est pourtant le seul
moyen de neutraliser le gaz qui restent
dans les réservoirs
jean-claude d'arrigo on leur disait où
allez vous il répondait par dizaines de
milliers on n'en sait rien mais on ne
veut pas rester ici
des bus pris d'assaut une fréquentation
des trains en augmentation de 60% à
bhopal depuis deux jours c'est la
panique
une panique provoquée par l'annoncé de
la reprise des activités de l'usiné de
laâyoune m carbide et du nettoyage des
cuves pour la population locale qui
continuent à voir mourir autour d'elle
qui sait qu'à l'hôpital le nombre des
aveugles des estropiés à vie augmente
pour ces hommes ces femmes et ces
enfants c'est la fuite qui s'impose une
fille folle sans but pour dans leur
esprit éviter le pire des informations
véhiculées par les journaux locaux
commence à trotter dans le grand public
on dit que depuis longtemps la sécurité
était négligée dans l'usiné de bhopal
qu'une fois de plus tout avait été
sacrifié au gros sous que les autorités
politiques locales savait et n'avait
rien dit demain doivent débuter des
opérations d'évacuation des 125 mille
personnes qui habitent où campent aux
alentours de lusine les 15 tonnes de gaz
qui reste en stock seront transformés en
pesticides à partir de dimanche matin la
police organisera un véritable transfert
de population et de bétail d'ores et
déjà la yunnan carbide c'est que la
catastrophe de bhopal lui coûtera si la
justice le condamne la bagatelle de 100
milliards de dollars soit 1000 milliards
de francs